[Musique]
mais ce qui me frappe quand on on y
repense enfin peu l'extérieur comme ça
c'est que la rue du château ça a été un
peu une sorte de phalanstère de l'amitié
oui puis un peu ça j'étais c'était un
bel endroit faisait chier on voyait
encore sur la porteuse chefs venus et c
c'était agréable l'instruction rester le
ce que c'est une offre avant de venir
une luxueuse maison édifiée par les
choix de marcel duhamel
c'est justement ce qui est bien c'est
que la salle de la mairie dirigée à
droite hôtels et là c'est juste moi un
petit hôtel comme avec les générosités
très particulière c'était très agréable
à vivre et beaucoup de gens pensaient la
plus tard d'autres gens vont passer et
puis maintenant c'est démoli reste plus
rien
exactement comme un endroit qui était
très jolie qui ressemblait à celle de
l'extérieur qui veut sa peau tremblante
été aidé à de lourdes
il trompe les contrats le passé ne reste
plus rien non plus si jolie ses
souvenirs qui sont complètement qu'elle
reçoit plus un souvenir est enlevé face
et plus est présent s'il ya pas deux
j'ai pas de souvenirs au fond si on sur
les box s'il y avait une image le
montrer ce serait mieux sans doute
croiser espère qu'on n'en pense rien
puis nous peut-être mais en même temps
cette rue du château ça devient une
espèce de chose mythique enfin chacun
imagine un peu à sa façon a oui vous
vous la voyez à votre manière duhamel la
voix la sienne
oui
ça ne m'emballe jama père et qui avait
habité là la voyez aussi d'une façon
justement andré breton qui venait
souvent la voix aussi façon générale
agréable par exemple si bien les gens
qui venaient jacquot meti robert desnos
que non' est souvent là beaucoup de gens
aragon a répondu oui
1 4 il a hélas hélas bits et après après
nous ne pas se laver
j'avais sadoul kiabi c'est après sa
doctrine et historiographe de cinéma il
a baissé la presse je suis plus parler
et bien ce qui ce qui m'a frappé dans ce
que disait duhamel c'est le côté maison
ouverte à tous les vents et à tous ceux
qui voulaient y entraient enfin s'était
jamais fermé non les chaouchi leur frère
puis a pris respect c'était votre hôtel
particulier montparnasse à tous étaient
encore montparnos sèchement je plains
montparnasse la flamme au palace où ces
beaux montparnasse l'on parle moi relate
aujourd'hui si les gens qui nous
écoutent
on le raconte à quartier le téléviseur
le téléspectateur pour l'air plutôt cool
été visionnaire il nous regarde en ce
moment c est nous écoute vous et moi
nous ne venons pas nous on est dans la
boîte il faut souvent s'adresser à eux
alors je peux leur dire moi je vous
parle d'une maison nous avons habité
avec des amis vous ne pouvez pas la voir
elle vous intéresse ou nous intéresse
pas mais chaleur
nous prenons nous pouvons avoir évoqué
existe j'espère que vous pensiez vous
l'avez j'ai raconté vers leur ensemble
ont vécu rassemble tout puissants sont
fâchés se sont disputés mais ces choses
restent là c'est vraiment quelque chose
c'est l'amitié vers finalement tous et
montparnasse c'est un prétexte à parler
de l'amitié à face à un prétexte à
parler d'une amitié chaude enfin l'amour
c'était ça m'en parler à son
définitivement aussi parce qu'on peut
toujours d'un métier enfin l'amour aussi
c'est le métier
par exemple le montparnasse moi je l'est
déjà
ouais j'ai pris moi par la soupe et
fille chez cegereal école rue lassïnce
les parcelles cette école visera la
passe pour un trait y avait des débats
des ateliers yves les modèles et ses
modèles manger regarder avec plaisir et
plus tard même j'ai longtemps préféré le
mode à la peinture moi j'ai pris du
montparnasse avant la guerre de 14
pendant la guerre de 14 après la guerre
de 14
aujourd'hui maintenant et si on les a
bombardés j'avais laissé mon mari aussi
mais ça jamais les prix et saint sulpice
sur les quartiers pour tous leur sein
comme vous de quartier
mais si on vient une seconde à la rue du
château un des personnages je crois les
plus les plus fascinants de la rue du
château c'était angui non sans images et
j'ai pu essayer à lunéville dans la
meurthe et moselle près de saint nicolas
du port gestion soldats dans leurs
chances tri de la peinture non je veux
pas de peinture et des comores de la
prison et c'est là où je les connais
c'était un personnage merveilleux après
vers le château et s'est mis à faire de
la peinture et c'est comme ça au fond je
suis moi même davantage intéressé à la
peinture
on m a rien à dire vous mieux mieux le
voir bien le connaître en bilingue et si
on racontait ses histoires personnelles
à la partie de cali margot camarades il
était extraordinaire ce breton d'abord
je suis motivé et englouti bretois à
part entière au mérite ou vernalde j'ai
mon père était la loire inférieure à des
boissons lui c'est un vrai breton et les
gens peuvent reconnaître enfin sa
peinture quelque chose de voitures de
même que les gens pas vos collègues dans
la peinture de picasso quelque chose
sûrement tous ces gars les to c est lui
même son visage et c'est la même chose
mais les et drôle très drôle
à ses moments perdus ou gagnés et je
crois que dès ce nom s'est beaucoup
intéressé à sa peinture aussi andernos
et sa merveilleuse amis et fait passer
dans la rue ont rencontré dans un besoin
d'argent vous ordonner que j'aurais
besoin qu'on leur donne et c'était ça
l'amitié
non c'est plus facile ça c'est pas le
même argent aujourd'hui qui passait rue
du château rauzé je viens toujours
beaucoup de gens parce que j'adore
depuis roland toile qui est mort jusqu'à
andré masson quand ça joue fort
montparnasse également c'était notre
quartier aussi qu'ils étaient réunis par
giacometti
j'ai longtemps demeurée jg comme et yves
je connais plus tard les couleurs du
château j'ai autant demeurer chez lui je
sais pas où aller ils habitent au même
endroit
il me donnait hospitalité j'aime
beaucoup je comité est ce qu'il fait
[Musique]